well let's talk to the mayor of london
sadiq khan good to see you this morning
can we talk about this to begin with
because i know there are there are 400
cases i think of indian variant reported
in the capital
so far would you support the idea
of just vaccinating all age groups now
well in general terms i understand the
advice from the government and the
experts to go by age
but actually in those parts of the
country where there are pockets of
people who have this indian variant i
think we should be nimble
and we should be giving the vaccine to
younger people in those areas
why because the early evidence is if you
receive the vaccine
less likely to catch this variant the
spread is less
serious but also the consequences should
you catch are less serious as well so i
think we should be nimble
and i've asked both matt hancock and
nazim zahabi the various ministers on
friday
to give us the flexibility to give
younger people the vaccine in those
parts of london
where we're concerned about this strain
i was going to say i mean for
somewhere the size of the capital i mean
you couldn't do it across the whole
population could you
and that's why i understand what the
government are saying and the health
advice across the country is what we're
saying though is uh
being nimble in relation to in those
pockets where we know there's an issue
let's uh use the vaccine sensibly so in
london the good news is
we're now testing everybody who's tested
positive
the the the gene sequence see whether
they've got this particular indian
variant so we know
which parts of our city there's a
concern and so we should be doing
in those particular boroughs is having a
hyper local approach
and encouraging those who are younger
who would have to wait a few weeks to
have the vaccine
now to avoid this strain spreading i
mean do you have the authority to do
that
i mean could you as we're seeing in
bolton they just seem to have said we're
just going to do it
do you have that authority well it's the
nhs who administer the vaccine they're
working incredibly hard it's been a
great success with
local communities the nhs have got to
follow the advice from
up above that's why i approached matt
hancock and deemed highway on friday
asking for this flexibility which i
think is really important the the virus
isn't rigid and doesn't follow rigid
rules and we've got to be nimble
in relation to our response to it i mean
the the problem you're going to face in
the capital
presumably is where you have these
various pockets
i mean one other thing that is going to
change today is you we are going to see
more people back on public transport
back on the buses back on the tubes
it's going to spread isn't it well a
number of things firstly the good news
now versus uh the peak in last winter
was we have reduced
the amount of people with the virus by
98 we've reduced those in hospital by uh
90 because people made sacrifices but
also we finally have
an effective test and trace system so
anybody who tests positive we can
trace who they've been in contact with
and that's why i'm encouraging all
londoners and those across the country
test regularly you can get free lateral
flow tests test twice a week
as a habit and separately take a pcr
test regularly the good news in london
is
if somebody does a pcr test and they
unfortunately test positive we check
what strain they've got and also we
track and trace as well i mean obviously
today with things opening up i know
you're sort of heading a campaign to try
and get more people out about and eating
in london which yeah i know a lot of
people are going to want to do it i
don't think you're going to have a huge
amount of problem getting persuading
people
but i mean it's a it's a difficult sort
of circle to square
is that in that you've got you know
you've you've got to protect
the capitals businesses whilst
protecting the population
yeah look the health of individuals is
linked with the health of our economy
but here's the good news uh you know
cool bars uh
you know uh restaurants uh cultural uh
attractions uh
hospitality venues they work so hard to
make sure their places are covered
safe of course we're gonna still follow
the rules social distance watch your
hands regularly and thoroughly
uh we're a face mask you can use public
transport
but i think londoners and those across
the country are wearing to go
in a safe way so we've begun the biggest
domestic tourism campaign london's ever
seen encouraging londoners
to come back to the west end and
encourage those across the country who
may be a bit crustful and they can't go
in the international holidays don't
worry
everything you need is in london i was
going to say because that's that's
ultimately the problem isn't it with a
lack of international and
and national tourists and the hybrid
working which means people aren't just
popping out to
buy a sandwich in the lunch hour what
have you i mean that football is going
to be well down
well here's the good news this is
probably the only spring and summer
when you aren't competing against
international tourists so you can go to
the world's best museums and galleries
not need to queue
you can get a booking at one of our best
restaurants without needing to get a
book in and it's really important
that we of course have a good time stay
safe but also protect jobs
and the reality is one out of five
londoners works in hospitality
or culture and so you can safely uh have
a great time
but also support british business look
and it's nice to have a positive outlook
i think we all want a little bit of ad
at the moment
and on the less positive front can i
just ask you about the anti-semitism
obviously
the situation that's going on in israel
and
gaza is hugely concerning and people can
have their views on that
but what we have seen is some incidents
in london
and if you've seen the clips on youtube
and what have you i mean
some absolute vile language which is
which is anti-semitic
absolutely vile now now what can what
are you doing to protect to try and calm
the temperature on that and
and protect the jewish community in
london well i've been i've been in
contact this weekend with
both the commissioner and deputy
commissioner and the police working
incredibly hard and it's important
for me to make this point and it's
possible at the same time
to be very angry about what's happening
in israel and gaza and the west bank
and be heartbroken at the death and to
call for
a ceasefire and a de-escalation what's
not excusable is on the other hand to
use as an excuse to be anti-semitic and
to be
racist there can be no excuse for that
so
jewish londoners in particular will see
in communities where they live
but also synagogues and jewish schools
and increased
police presence just to make you feel
safe but also to make sure anybody who's
involved
in any race crimes and they are crimes
by the way
uh action is taken and it's important
for us to realize
that actually uh the impact of
this criminal behavior has a ripple of
fear effect on jewish londoners and
those across the country
and it's really important that we don't
bring conflicts 3 000 miles away
to the capital city okay steve khan good
to talk to you thank you